I don't know you what do you think I
knew this is the weirdest thing I think
we have like a third caller in is there
a color from 757 who's also on with us
right now
hey David can you hear me
yeah and hold on Jonathan are you still
on as well
yeah we've got a three-way call going on
all right Jonathan join me in taking
this next call who's who's calling from
757 hi my name is autumn
I'm calling from Norfolk Virginia all
right autumn you're on with Pat David
and also our previous caller Jonathan go
ahead hi Jonathan um so I am actually
from Nevada I'm active duty and I was
able to keep my um my residency there so
this is kind of near and dear to me I
was wondering if you were following the
Nevada Senate race in 2018 with Dean
Heller and all of them yes I was um so a
couple things my um my concern is I'm
not going to vote for Dean Heller no
matter what I think Jesus please : but
my concern is is if we get rid of you
know the Heller's and Murkowski
whoever's that the moderates in the
Senate that the Republican Party just
you know gets more extreme or terrible I
agree with you I agree with you and this
is something we've been contending with
for a while actually this idea of how do
you what happens and by the way the idea
that we even call some of these people
moderates is only because the the
spectrum has shifted so far to the right
these are moderates in 2017 but I don't
actually really think of them as
political moderates Jonathan do you have
strong feelings here about Adams
question Jonathan Scott okay I wish but
a minute stayed with wood voting out
Dean Heller reinvigorate your hope in
humanity yeah that's if that's a fair
question
if Dean Heller goes autumn would you be
more optimistic in general about the
political system aside from what happens
to these moderates
um that's that's a tough one
all right well listen I'll go ahead yeah
I was gonna ask you if you were so your
active duty have you served overseas um
I so funny story I was supposed to my
first orders war for South Korea but I
got those polt because I made the
decision the stupid decision to tell
them the truth
who told him that I smoked pot twice in
high school I'm sorry you say I when you
go to enlist and do all that they have a
medical screening and they have like a
little clearance thing yeah and I told
them when I was 15 years old that I had
smoked weed Oh
and they're like all right we'll let you
in but nine months later find out Oh
supposed to go to Korea just kidding you
smoked weed and so that led to you just
not going to Korea to Korea didn't have
other consequences
um no didn't have any other consequences
all right autumn I'm great to hear from
you and very clearly you pronounced that
Nevada and that is the correct
pronunciation right yes that is the
correct pronunciation I don't know where
Nevada comes from but it makes me cringe
good all right good autumn thanks so
much for the call I appreciate it
thank you take care